what's Popp and variant it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
after Loki episode 3 introduced us to
the origins of Kang through his snake
oil salesman of a variant Victor timley
the ambitious Rona Ren Slayer learns
that there is a deep dark secret that he
who remains was keeping from her during
her countless eons of servitude as
director of the TVA a revelation that
would render Rona Rens Slayer enraged
but what could that big secret be and
also how exactly could both Victor
timley and Ora Boris factor into the
secret Sinister plans of he who remains
and while we're at it let's talk about
the potential applications of a
miniaturized Time loon and how a tiny
time loom in the wrong hands could
potentially spell trouble for the future
so let's dive into all of this Carnival
chaos together my nerd babies all right
so let's begin this video by talking
about raona Ren Slayer and the secret
Miss minutes is going to tell raona
that's going to make her real mad and I
have a feeling that the secret most
likely has to do with ravona Ren Slayer
having been betrayed by he who remains
in the past because let's face it so far
in the MCU Kang doesn't have the best
reputation for loyalty and teamwork so
much so that the entire Multiverse is
now at risk because the Council of Kang
gang started beefing with each other for
territory like this was freaking TVA San
Andreas and this incredibly strong
capacity for selfishness is a
personality trait that is deeply seated
within Kang's nature it seems as we can
see it manifest in Kang's early days
when he was just the inventor of Victor
timely especially when he tells that
interested buyer of his imperfect mini
time Loom that he doesn't do partners
[Music]
no I don't do partners and we of course
see that selfish mentality come out
again later in the episode when he
betrays raona after she revealed that
her motivation to work with him was
purely out of professional gain while
Victor timley on the other hand wanted
someone to have a romance with I have my
hopes for this
[Music]
partnership
you heard her Victor
partnership you had to do it and
considering how the TVA boardroom
recording from episode 1 reveals a
conversation between Kang and ren Slayer
that has Kang thanking Ren Slayer for
making a difference in the multiversal
war of the past teasing at a close
relationship between the two the most
likely scenario to me is that the
version of Kang who would become he who
remains cheated Rona Ren Slayer out of a
high position of autonomy and power
likely a position equal to that of kangs
himself as his co-c conqueror because if
you know anything about Rona Ren Slayer
from the comics then you know that she
and Kang have a tightly knit and
extremely complicated toxic history
together both as passionate lovers and
as bitter enemies in combat and conquest
and it's during a period of intense
hatred towards Kang that ravona Ren
Slayer becomes the badass Savage of a
warrior who calls herself the
terminatrix a name that was actually
teased during the Loki finale when
Hunter B 15 tracks down Ren slayer's
vice principal of aarian by the name of
Rebecca tormin with tormin of course
hinting at the terminatrix now this all
being said much like Rebecca tor's fate
was written by he who remains to be a
vice principal at a high school and not
a full-on principal he who remains
likely wanted his Ren Slayer variant to
be a vice head of the TVA and not one of
the people with ultimate Authority like
him Kang is an astronomically selfish
person who does not like having long
term Partners at all and raona ren
Slayer unfortunately possesses an
ambition that seeks to rival his own
even if he who remains did feel deep
affection for RONA Ren slayer at some
point in the past like K did in the
comics his selfishness would inevitably
keep him from sharing anything that he's
conquered with her likely due to a
deeply seated fear of betrayal rooted in
him due to Kang seeing so much of his
own ambitious self within raona so I
wouldn't be too surprised to hear if
raona runs Slayer was immediately
betrayed and mind wiped by Kang after
his victory in the time War so that
ravona forgot her promised seat at the
end of time while still being awarded
for her service by being allowed to call
all the shots in the TVA as the tva's
Director and this would very much be a
perfect metaphor for a toxic
relationship in my opinion because it
shows that Kang would much rather
manipulate ravona into remaining his
useful possession than trust in her as a
person and equal partner and this is a
big reason why I believe a bitter Miss
minutes is even offering to tell this
information to ravona in the first place
because Missin knows that giving raona
this Intel will likely serve to get
raona on her side because Miss minut is
not a human who can interact with other
humans and she needs help you know since
they were both women who he remains only
saw as tools dedicated to him and
nothing more after eon's OBS Service as
a floating cartoon Consciousness Miss
Min felt betrayed that he who remains
never considered giving her a body once
before he decided to enact his plan to
unal Alive himself so now miss Min is
seeking her own free will just like
ravona is and since Victor timely just
rejected her confession of love Miss
minutes now sees an opportunity to
become allies with raona since they have
both become enemies of their enemy but
now let us move on to talking about why
he who remains could have done all of
this to both raona and miss minut and
how the events of Loki episode 3 could
potentially explain a lot of heu remains
his mysterious motivations and I think
it all boils down to the overall Ora
Boris theme of this season of Loki like
I said in my Loki episode 2 Theory video
that you can check out here the Ora
Boris symbol is super important to this
season of Loki because it depicts a
snake or a dragon eating their own tail
and because this serpent paradoxically
eats themselves to restore themselves
the Orab Boris has been known as a
symbol of both creation and destruction
throughout various cultures and
mythologies the Ora Boris theme seems to
be incredibly influential this season as
a man named Ora Boris has been charged
with fixing the giant Cosmic Ora Boris
that is the sacred timeline with the
temporal Loom acting as the head of the
slithery Sacred timeline that is
currently choking on its overly
branching Tails all while being wrapped
around the TVA much like the Norse
serpent yman Gander wraps itself around
the world in Norse mythology like I said
I go over all of this in that episode 2
video so check that out if you haven't
already now the reason why I'm bringing
up the Ora borus theme again in this
episode 3 Centric video is to get you
guys to realize how it relates to he who
remains his overall plan because to me
Loki episode 3 is showing us that Kang
is a man who was always meant to create
his own damn self the self-destruction
of he who remains led to the creation of
Victor timy's obsession with time with
the implication possibly being that King
the Conqueror always creates himself
before destroying himself in the end
with Ora boris' writings in the TVA
handbook serving as the main catalyst
for the conqueror's creation implying to
me that there have been multiple
multiversal Kang wars in the past with
the actual winner of those Wars becoming
he who remains and ruling at the end of
time before sending a copy of the TVA
handbook back in time to himself right
before he kills himself so he can ensure
Victor timley becomes Kang in an
unending cycle because you got to
remember one super important thing from
this episode raona dropped the TVA
handbook off in young Victor timy's life
while she was visiting the sacred
timeline itself not one of the newly
born Branch timelines like sylv's
McDonald's timeline this being the case
this means that ravona dropping that
book off to a young Victor timely was
always supposed to happen as part of he
who remains his plan because that that's
how he believes his life is supposed to
go meaning that that actually did happen
in the past of he who remains as well I
believe this is how Kang was always
meant to begin his journey as a time
traveling conqueror with the Kang
remaining at the end of time sending his
younger self a book with everything he
needs to know to begin all the secrets
about the TVA and manipulating time in
general this way even in death Kang
knows that he always comes back to win
his ultimate seat at the end of time as
he who remains because he's very very
likely won this multiversal war over and
over and over again however what makes
the Victor timely variant from episode 3
special from the infinite amount of Kang
variants that have branched since Ren
Slayer first dropped off that book on
the sacred timeline is that he
specifically is very likely the version
of Kang who will become the new
reincarnated variant of he who remains
because that variant has the one thing
that no other Victor timely variants
have a unique experience with ravona Ren
Slayer Miss minutes Mobius and most
importantly Loki and Sylvie yeah all
those variants might have ob's book but
this episode 3 Victor timely is probably
having the same exact experience with
Loki and Sylvie that he who remains had
when he first started off in Chicago all
those years ago and I believe that it is
because of this wild experience of
meeting Ren Slayer and Miss minutes
running from Sylvie and having Mobius
and Loki save his life that he who
remains chose all those people as his
pawns to end his his life in Loki season
1 because we cannot forget that
everything that is happening in Loki
season 2 is all he who remains as will
he planned everything out from the jump
every single chaotic element of this
season was supposed to happen the way
it's been happening because he who
remains specifically had gone through
all of that before like all this dude
had to do was tell Miss minutes to give
Ren Slayer a book and that book would
act as the first Domino that would
trigger a Cascade of chaos that would
inevitably lead Victor Timely to
becoming the exact Reincarnation of Kang
that Sylvie dreads the most he who
remains a cosmic game of chess triggered
by his favorite chess partner of all
time Miss minutes he who remains was the
only version of Kang with the Loki
season 2 episode 3 experience which
means to me that the Victor timely from
that episode who met all of these TVA
people is the exact seed that he who
remains wanted to sew for his return to
the end of time other branched King
variants will inevitably Sprout because
RN Slayer put that book down with the
young Victor time but it is this Victor
timely variant specifically from episode
3 that is the center of he who remains
his reincarnation plans like this is all
just entertainment for a bored man at
the end of time who wanted the cosmos to
experience the exact same wild events
that happened that led he who remains to
Victory after a massive multiversal time
war between all these other kings this
all being said because of what happened
to him in episode 3 Victor timley will
probably go on to create Mis minutes
develop a relationship with an earlier
version of run Slayer and choose to make
Loki and sylv's lives a living hell also
he who remains can remain on top in the
end like this dude is playing 5D chess
from the grave right now it's freaking
nuts but anyways before I end this video
I want to talk about Victor timely's
temporal Loom and how we could
potentially see a miniaturized temporal
Loom be used to weave together even more
crazy chaos for the future of the MCU if
you watched my Loki episode 1 video
where I explain what temporal Aura is
and why a temporal Aura extractor needed
to be used on the rainbow energies of
the sacred timeline I highly recommend
that you give that one a watch because I
genuinely think it's some good stuff and
will help you understand what's going on
here but essentially I explain that
every living being in the MCU has a
rainbow aura that makes up their life
force and that is their temporal Aura
and this is why people glow rainbow when
they get pruned by TVA sticks and why
wenwu had rainbow energy being sucked
out of him by that super sold sucker of
a dragon in shanqi and the reason for
this is because during the Big Bang an
unfathomable amount of these six
Infinity energies filled the entire
blank dark canvas of the universe with
color and the natural laws of science
like gravity Dark Energy Dark Matter
regular matter Etc and each of those
infinity stone colors represents these
core parts of science but anyways this
is what Victor timely meant in his time
Loom presentation when he speaks about
harnessing the power of time that exists
all around them because the entire
Marvel universe is just a mishmash of
all the infinity stone energies
organized together to create order the
natural law when the
energy of the past present and future
flows
all around us which is why Cosmic
microwave background radiation or cmbr
was such a huge Focus point in Wanda
Vision because Wanda was manipulating
the chaos and mindstone infinity
energies within her to create a new
reality but anyways for the sake of time
I'm just going to skip all the
complicated sciency stuff because the
main point that you need to know here is
that the temporal Aura of human beings
is the same energy that runs through the
sacred timeline itself and the temporal
Loom this being said if the temporal
Loom attached to the sacred timeline can
weave the rainbow energies of the
timeline into any shape that it wants
that it stands to reason that a
miniaturized temporal Loom could
potentially weave the temporal auras of
multiple people into a singular being
like for example if OB were to tamper
with his temporal AA extractor and make
it into a mini temporal Loom then he
could do something crazy like merge his
own temporal Aura with that of the
business-minded Victor timley to create
an entirely new being possibly a new
being known as Mr Griffin that variant
would be a perfect mish mash of both of
those people to create a truly
formidable new king variant from scratch
but that's not all because remember the
ending of quantum Mania when Quantum
Mania Kang got sucked into his
malfunctioning machine before a blast of
energy got sent out everywhere I have a
feeling that quantam Mania Kang did not
die at all there but was turned into
pure temporal energy a type of energy
from the Marvel Comics that K turns into
called a Quantum temporal way if someone
were to construct a mini temporal or a
loom they could theoretically extract
Quantum Mania Kang's energies and
reconstruct his body just in time for
Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars I mean if
the TVA can manipulate and weave
together the infinity energies of the
Sacred timeline with a Time Loom then
the infinity energies within living
beings can be manipulated and woven as
well like it would kind of be crazy if
something happened to cause Loki and
Sylvie to be woven together by the end
of the series to create a completely new
version of Loki who has confronted all
of his demons and has learned to love
himself and others on a much deeper
level like I feel like that type of
Union would be super special in my
opinion rather than you know them being
in a relationship cuz that's kind of
weird but anyways thanks so much for
watching everybody like I love this
episode so much and I wish I had more
time to fully explain the science behind
Victor timy's time Loom presentation
because it's some really interesting and
exciting stuff in my opinion like I got
so freaking excited when he started
talking I was like oh my God this man is
speaking my language but in order for me
to explain all that I would have to
fully explain the infinity stone science
of the MCU that I call the Marvel
trigger Theory and that would be much
better served as its own separate video
another time because good God is that a
very complex subject but trust me once
you understand it you will see how it
affects pretty much every single MCU
project since the days of the Incredible
Hulk and Iron Man 2 I promise you it's
literally the greatest thing I've ever
done I freaking love the Marvel trigger
theory if you guys want to see a video
about that let me know in the comment
section below and I'll make that happen
it's literally the thing that excites me
the most about the MCU hands down but
anyways you can follow me at
mastertainment on Twitter if you guys
want to see me tweet some really fun
theories and really weird but most
importantly do not forget to follow
heavy spoilers here on YouTube because
we got some really great stuff for you
on the regular but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching I love you
guys so much and I'll see you guys later
goodbye